présidente monsieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues nous entendons
ce matin madame Karine cambie présidente
de la première chambre de la Cour des
comptes et membre du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques
vous venez madame nous présenter pas
moins de 4 documents le rapport sur le
budget de l'État en 2022
l'acte de certification des comptes de
l'État pour la même année et enfin les
avis du Haut conseil sur les projets de
loi de règlement de 2021 et 2022 ces
documents permettent d'avoir un regard
très complet sur les comptes publics et
plus particulièrement sur les comptes de
l'État en 2022
le rapport de la Cour accompagné de 64
notes d'exécution budgétaire offre une
analyse extrêmement riche de l'ensemble
des dépenses et recettes de l'État
je pense que c'est plutôt le caractère
rétrospectif de ces documents qui fait
que certains de nos collègues ne nous
ont pas rejoint mais peut-être vont-ils
arriver avec quelques minutes de retard
l'acte de certification des comptes de
l'État valide le caractère dans
l'ensemble sincère des comptes avec
toutefois des réserves notables et
persistantes ce n'est pas une simple
formalité on a vu cette année que la
Cour a refusé de certifier les comptes
de la branche famille de la sécurité
sociale et de la Caisse nationale des
allocations familiales
enfin la vidéo conseil sur le projet de
loi de règlement pour 2022 rappelle
l'état très dégradé de nos finances
publiques
après l'audition du ministre chargé des
comptes publics Gabriel Attal le 2 mai
dernier votre audition s'inscrit dans le
cadre des travaux de la commission sur
le contrôle de l'exécution 2022 dans la
perspective de l'examen du projet de loi
de règlement qui devrait être intervenir
début juillet en séance
contrairement à l'an dernier le projet
de loi de règlement a en effet été
présenté dès le 13 avril ce qui nous
donne davantage de temps pour l'examiner
nous devrons également examiner une
seconde fois le projet de loi de
règlement pour 2021 puisqu'il avait été
rejeté l'an passé et a été déposé une
seconde fois par le gouvernement
je vous rappelle que
notre audition cette audition est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et donc madame la
Présidente
[Musique]
c'est à présent la parole pour un exposé
liminaire qui se poursuivra comme cette
traditionnelle par un jeu de questions
et réponses merci Madame la présente
merci beaucoup monsieur le
vice-président monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais tout d'abord vous
présenter et vous transmettre les
regrets du premier président de la Cour
des comptes qui n'a pas pu être présent
avec vous ce matin et qui m'a donc
demandé de le représenter je voudrais
bien sûr comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le vice-président vous
présenter plusieurs
rapports de la Cour des comptes mais
aussi du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques comme vous le savez la
publication de ces rapports est un
moment très important pour la Cour des
comptes et pour ces magistrats qui sont
très nombreux à travailler sur ces
documents et qui sont particulièrement
attachés à leur mission d'assistance au
Parlement dans le contrôle de
l'exécution budgétaire
donc je suis accompagnée ici par les
principaux artisans de ces travaux
monsieur gianesini Bazeilles et
Vareilles et Madame aberhardt pour le
rapport sur le budget de l'État rapport
comme vous l'avez rappelé dans la
publication est accompagnée de 64 notes
d'exécution budgétaire Monsieur Laurent
Serrat pour la certification des comptes
de l'État et Monsieur
Eric Dubois qui est le secrétaire
général du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques alors
il nous semble que de du rapport sur le
budget de l'État il convient de retenir
4 idées fortes pour l'année 2022 le
premier c'est que le rapport sur le
budget de l'État fait apparaître le
maintien d'un niveau très élevé de
déficit qui pèse sur le volume de la
dette alors même que l'inflation en a
augmenté le coût
le second message c'est qu'il y a un
dynamisme exceptionnel des recettes nous
y reviendrons qui sont en forte
progression mais il y a également une
très forte progression des dépenses et
donc cela n'a contribué qu'un
suffisamment à la réduction du déficit
en troisième lieu le rapport formule des
recommandations pour améliorer la
lisibilité du budget et renforcer la
portée de l'autorisation parlementaire
afin
j'attirerai votre attention sur les
risques d'identifier le rapport pour
l'avenir notamment le poids grandissant
des lois de programmation qui prévoit
des crédits supplémentaires pour
certaines politiques publiques et
l'impact attendu de la hausse des
intérêts des taux d'intérêts sur la
charge de la dette donc le premier
message c'est celui d'un déficit
toujours élevé d'une progression
continue de l'endettement et d'une forte
hausse de la charge de la dette en 2022
le déficit du budget de l'État s'est
établi à
151,4 milliards d'euros c'est en légère
baisse par rapport à 2021 puisque le
déficit c'était élevé à 170 milliards
malgré cette baisse il reste très élevé
par rapport aux années antérieures à
titre de comparaison en 2019 le déficit
était de 92,7 milliards
alors permettez-moi en tant que membre
du Haut Conseil est représentant
aujourd'hui son président Pierre
Moscovici de rappeler que le solde de
l'ensemble des comptes publics c'est à
dire non seulement de l'État mais aussi
de ces opérateurs des administrations de
sécurité sociale et des collectivités
territoriales et de leurs opérateurs
représentent encore un déficit de 4,7
points de PIB en 2022 contre 6,5 points
l'année précédente le sol de structurel
qui neutralise les effets de la
conjoncture ainsi que les mesures
temporaires s'élèvent à 3,4 points de
PIB potentiel même s'il est nettement
réduit par rapport à 2021 puisqu'il
atteigna 4,4 points de PI potentiel
une introduction de ce déficit
structurel est encore indispensable pour
réduire l'exposition de la France à un
risque d'insoutenabilité de la dette
en effet l'évolution du solde structurel
présenté par le gouvernement pour 2022
et supérieur de 2,6 points à la
prévision retenue dans la loi de
programmation pour les finances
publiques de
2018-2022 cet écart est très nettement
supérieur vous l'aurez noté au 0,5
points de Pibe qui aurait pu justifier
le déclenchement d'un mécanisme de
correction si la clause de circonstances
exceptionnelle s'appliquait je rappelle
que la Commission européenne a d'ores et
déjà proposé de lever cette clause au
1er janvier prochain et nous reviendrons
donc à des règles qu'il convient encore
de préciser le Haut Conseil invite par
conséquent dans son avis le gouvernement
a précisé rapidement les conditions de
la levée de cette clause de
circonstances exceptionnelle ainsi que
son calendrier
j'en reviens maintenant au budget de
l'État
en conséquence du niveau élevé de
déficit la dette a moyen et long terme
de l'État a continué sa progression le
volume de dette a augmenté de 24 % en 3
ans passant de 1823 milliards d'euros
fin 2019 à 2278 milliards d'euros fin
2022 le besoin de financement de me
relever 280 milliards d'euros en 2022 et
il est supérieur de 60 milliards d'euros
à 2019
dans un contexte où à cet endettement
élevé s'ajoute une forte inflation et
une augmentation des taux d'intérêt la
charge de la dette constitue évidemment
un point d'attention extrêmement
important une première augmentation de
cette charge de la dette avait été
observée en 2021 mais elle était limitée
à 2 milliards d'euros en 2022 nous
constatons une rupture très nette que la
charge de la dette a progressé de 13,2
milliards d'euros pour atteindre 50,7
milliards d'euros en 2022 ce qui
représente une augmentation de 35%.
cette augmentation n'avait pas été
anticipée par la loi de finance initiale
qui prévoyait une charge de 38,7
milliards d'euros le principal facteur
de hausse n'est cependant pas à ce stade
la hausse des taux dont les effets ne se
sont pas encore fait sentir sur le stock
de dettes mais l'inflation qui s'est
traduite par une augmentation de près de
12 milliards d'euros des provisions pour
charges d'indexation des titres indexés
sur l'inflation
afin de limiter la croissance de la
charge de la date dans ce contexte de
reprise de l'inflation la cour
recommande donc d'actualiser rapidement
la doctrine sur les conditions
d'émissions des titres indexées
la hausse des taux si elle devait être
durable pourrait cependant exercer à
long terme une pression très supérieure
à celle de l'inflation sur la charge de
la date et réduire en conséquence nos
marges de manœuvre budgétaire
l'impact de la remontée des taux sera
appelé à pesée davantage à partir de
2023 et l'Agence France Trésor estime
qu'une hausse de 100 points de base des
taux d'intérêt renchérit la charge
d'intérêt de 2,5 milliards la première
année de 6 milliards la deuxième année
est de 30 milliards à l'horizon de 10
ans l'impact serait donc considérable et
pourrait limiter drastiquement comme je
le disais à l'instant les marges de
manœuvre budgétaires
le second message de ce rapport concerne
bien sûr le dynamisme des recettes qui
apprennent une forte progression en 2021
continue d'être exceptionnel en 2022
l'année 2022 a donc été marqué par ce
dynamisme les recettes du budget général
ont progressé de 32 milliards en 2022 et
cette progression s'explique
principalement par la forte augmentation
spontanée des recettes fiscales et non
par des mesures nouvelles
les recettes fiscales ont donc atteint
en 2022 323 milliards d'euros c'est un
record historique cette croissance a
notamment été tirée par la hausse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés ainsi que par
la hausse de la TVA elle est d'autant
plus notable qu'il y a eu des mouvements
à la baisse notamment la taxe intérieure
sur la consommation finale d'électricité
qui a baissé de près de 5 milliards
d'euros dans le cadre de la mise en
place du bouclier tarifaire mais
également la suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle qui a pesé à hauteur de
3,6 milliards d'euros à la baisse sur
les recettes de TVA
comme lors des deux exercices précédents
le rapport fait apparaître un enjeu
d'amélioration des prévisions de
recettes fiscales et une meilleure
information sur les facteurs d'évolution
des recettes dans les documents
budgétaires en effet l'écart qui est
observé entre l'exécution et la dernière
loi de finance rectificative et
substantielle
7,5 milliards d'euros la cour recommande
donc de fournir de manière précise dans
les documents budgétaires à l'occasion
des lois de finances rectificatives des
éléments permettant de justifier pour
chacun des grands impôts les nouvelles
estimations de recettes fiscales et
l'origine des écarts avec les prévisions
des lois de finances initiale ou
rectificatives antérieures
d'autre part l'année 2022 a été marquée
par une nouvelle augmentation des
dépenses de l'État et ce malgré un très
net reflux des dépenses d'urgence
sanitaire et de relance
la Cour constate donc la France n'est
pas sortie du quoi qu'il en coûte au
risque de créer une situation anormale
de dépendance à la dépense
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
les dépenses du budget général ont
augmenté de 33% depuis 2019
l'année 2022 c'est bien sûr caractérisé
par un choc inflationniste
et par les conséquences de la guerre en
Ukraine qui ont conduit le gouvernement
à adopter en cours d'année la
programmation a adapté pardon en cours
d'année la programmation de la loi de
finances initiale ainsi malgré une
baisse de plus de 47 milliards de
dépenses d'urgence sanitaire et de
relance les dépenses budgétaires les
dépenses du budget général de l'État ont
progressé de 19 milliards en 2022
si on neutralise les dépenses d'urgence
et du relance cette augmentation des
dépenses en 2022 et de 66 milliards
12 milliards concernent les dépenses
relatives aux mesures énergies et
inflation 10 milliards la dotation en
vue de la renationalisation intégrale de
DF 13 milliards la charge d'intérêt de
la dette enfin son augmentation et les
autres dépenses 31 milliards
représentent des augmentations qui
tiennent en fait aux dépenses ordinaires
de l'État c'est à dire principalement
ces dépenses de fonctionnement et sa
masse salariale alors je voudrais
m'arrêter une seconde sur les dépenses
de personnel car malgré une baisse
notable des effectifs qui n'étaient pas
attendus puisque la loi de finance
initiale prévoyait une augmentation
nette des créations d'emplois
il y a eu une diminution des effectifs
en ETP de près de 5800 ETTP en 2022 plus
forte qu'en 2021
ces diminutions se concentrent surtout
sur les ministères de l'Éducation de
l'économie et des armées et sur le
ministère de la transition écologique en
dépit de cette situation qui montre une
certaine baisse d'attractivité peut-être
de l'emploi public dans un contexte
quand même de fortes tensions sur le
marché du travail les dépenses de
personnel atteignent 138,8 milliards
d'euros en 2022 donc 14
94,5 milliards de rémunération et 44,4
milliards de contributions au compte
d'affectation spéciale pension
l'augmentation des rémunérations et bien
sûr portée par la revalorisation du
point d'indice qui pèse pour 1,4
milliards d'euros sur la masse salariale
en 2022 et pour un milliard d'euros en
revalorisation catégoriale
enfin le coût des dépenses fiscales
augmentent également de 4,6 milliards
d'euros en 2022 pour atteindre un total
de
94,2 milliards d'euros notamment sous
l'effet de la très forte hausse de la
taxation forfaitaire au tonnage des
entreprises de transport maritimes qui
est proportionnelle aux chiffres
d'affaires de ces entreprises la
maîtrise des dépenses fiscales
continuent donc de constituer un enjeu
important dans le pilotage du sol de
budgétaire à ce titre la Cour constate à
nouveau le caractère inopérant des
mécanismes destinés en stabiliser le
nombre il y a 465 mesures de dépenses
fiscale recensées dans le PLF pour 2023
et le coût de ses dépenses fiscales
sachant que les évaluations qui devaient
être réalisées pour éventuellement les
ajuster ou les supprimer non dans
l'ensemble
pas été réalisé
mon troisième point concerne
l'autorisation parlementaire donnée par
la loi de finances en effet le rapport
met en lumière ainsi que important de
sous-consommation et de report de crédit
ce cycle a été initié en 2020 et
poursuivi en 2021
dans le contexte de la crise sanitaire
et énergétique le gouvernement en effet
inscrit en loi de finances initiale et
rectificative des enveloppes larges de
crédit allant parfois au-delà des
enveloppes prévisibles cette situation a
conduit à une sous-consommation des
crédits de
24,6 milliards en 2022
comme en 2021 après 37,5 milliards en
2020 ces crédits au lieu d'être annulés
ont été en grande partie reportées sur
l'exercice suivant les reports ont
atteint 23 milliards en 2021 il s'élève
encore à 18,7 milliards en 2022 ce sont
des niveaux très supérieurs au niveau
antérieur comme vous le voyez sur le
graphique qui est projeté
c'est pratique portent atteinte au
principe d'analualité elle s'interroge
aussi sur le respect du principe de
spécialité dans la mesure où c'est
redéploiement massif permis par les
reports sont susceptibles de bénéficier
à d'autres politiques publiques que
celles qui avait justifié notre
autorisation initiale la cour recommande
donc de n’ouvrir en loi de finances
initiale et rectificatif que les crédits
strictement nécessaires à l'exercice en
cours et bien sûr de limiter les reports
et d'apurer les autorisations
d'engagement affectées à des opérations
d'investissement qui seraient devenues
sans objet de façon globale il s'agit de
d'encourager à une gestion budgétaire
plus rigoureuse
le second point que je souhaiterais
aborder concerne le budget vert qui fait
l'objet d'un développement spécifique
dans le rapport comme vous le savez
depuis 2020 le gouvernement publie une
annexe au projet de loi de finance sur
le but l'impact environnemental du
budget de l'État ce qu'on appelle
communément le budget vert qui
s'apparente en réalité une démarche de
cotation
c'est une avancée importante qui nous
place
parmi les pays qui font le plus
d'efforts pour
identifier ces dépenses vertes cependant
la Cour estime qu'il y a des limites
encore importantes et qu'il y a des
marges de progression puisque seulement
10% des recettes des dépenses pardon son
côté favorable ou défavorable 90% des
dépenses aujourd'hui ne sont soit pas
côté soit côté neutre il y a donc comme
vous le voyez un travail approfondie à
réaliser et la cour publiera d'ailleurs
prochaine ment un rapport spécifique sur
ce sujet
enfin dernier point le rapport
identifie la complexification croissante
des relations entre l'État et les autres
administrations publiques à l'occasion
de la crise sanitaire le montant total
transféré par l'État aux collectivités
atteint 143 milliards d'euros en 2022
ce qui représente une hausse de 2,4%
notamment sous l'effet de nouvelles
affectations de TVA en compensation de
réforme fiscales récentes la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation et celle la
baisse des impôts de production
comme la cour lavait rappelé dans son
rapport public annuel 2023 le
financement prépondérant des
collectivités par la voie d'affectation
d'un poids et de prélèvement sur
recettes offre des ressources dynamiques
notamment en matière de TVA mais limite
aussi les possibilités de régulation
budgétaire pour l'État
la TVA devient également une ressource
déterminante de la protection sociale
laquelle n'est plus financée par les
cotisations que pour la moitié de ces
recettes la TVA représente 60% des 95
milliards d'impôts et taxes affectés à
la protection sociale
par ailleurs le budget de l'État comme
vous le savez finance également les
prestations sociales versées par les
caves pour 42 milliards en 2022 ce qui
dans un objectif de lisibilité et de
consentement à l'impôt et quand même un
peu opaque et mérite beaucoup
d'explications pour être compréhensible
enfin je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur les risques qui passent
sur la trajectoire budgétaire à venir
l'analyse de l'exécution du budget 2022
mais en lumière 3 grands risques
susceptibles d'affecter la soutenabilité
des finances publiques au cours du
prochain exercice le report des crédits
comme je l'évoquais tout à l'heure reste
important et se traduit par des restes à
payer qui sont très significatifs les
reports non consommés de 2022 sur 2023
s'élève à 8 milliards d'euros hors fonds
de concours et attribution de produits
contre 1 à 2 milliards avant la crise et
5,2 milliards de crédit non consommés
sur la mission économique ont été
reportées ces reports autorisés par la
LFI pour 2023 concerne 40 programmes
ce nombre important d'exemption ne peut
plus se justifier comme précédemment par
l'incertitude découlant de la crise
sanitaire les restes à payer atteignent
214 milliards fin 2022 ils augmentent
très sensiblement également enfin
dernier point les lois de programmation
sectorielle au nombre de 5
rigidifie drastiquement la dépense elle
représente 20% du budget de l'État en
2023 et contraindront fortement à
l'avenir les autres dépenses
un dernier mot pour terminer sur la
certification des comptes de l'État il
convient de rappeler que pour la
première fois depuis que la Cour
certifie les comptes de l'État les
comptes de l'exercice 2021 n'ont pas été
approuvé par le Parlement comme vous le
rappeliez monsieur le vice-président
dans votre propos introductif aussi même
si l'administration a trouvé une
solution comptable
pour porter ce le déficit de l'exercice
2021 dans les contes de l'État celui-ci
n'a pas pu être affecté au report à
nouveau ce qui évidemment ne constitue
pas une bonne pratique
en second lieu la Cour a constaté un
certain progrès dans la qualité des
comptes puisqu'elle ne relève plus que 4
anomalies significatives qu'on peut
considérer comme des réserves contre 5
en 2021 et la levée de ces anomalies qui
constituent plutôt des points de
principe
sur la présentation des contes
pourraient être levé si l'État le
souhaitait le nombre
d'insuffisance d'éléments probants qui
constituent en fait plutôt des points
sur lesquels la Cour n'a pas obtenu les
informations nécessaires pour se
prononcer
sont au nombre de 13 contre 10 en 2021
il s'agit notamment du montant des
engagements de retraite des
fonctionnaires civils et militaires de
l'état des charges relatives au bouclier
tarifaires déployés en 2022 ou de la
valeur du patrimoine immobilier de
l'État
je rappellerai que dans les contes de
l'État pour l'essentiel les principes de
la comptabilité d'entreprise sont
appliquées c'est une comptabilité en
droit constatée donc bien évidemment
les soldes ne sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes de même que les montants de
dépenses et de recettes ainsi et c'est
la slide suivante alors que le déficit
de l'État s'est amélioré de 19 milliards
en comptabilité budgétaire il s'est
dégradé de 19 milliards en comptabilité
générale et atteint moins 160 milliards
d'euros les charges de fonctionnement
sont en hausse alors que les charges
d'intervention sont stables et les
constats globalement sont quand même
identiques à ceux que je viens de vous
exposer ce qu'il faut remarquer c'est
qu'au bilans il y a une insuffisance
d'active de 1758 milliards d'euros et
donc en endettement financier de 2500
milliards d'euros
contre
2368 milliards un an plus tôt enfin le
montant des engagements orbilans atteint
4000 milliards d'euros au 31 décembre
2022 en conclusion comme vous l'avez dit
la course certifie avec réserve le
compte général de l'État elle estime
qu'on regarde du recueil des normes
comptables il est régulier et sincère et
donne une image fidèle du résultat des
opérations de l'exercice écoulé et de la
situation du patrimoine de l'État je
vous remercie
nous allons donc procéder à un certain
nombre de questionnements bien sûr pour
approfondir
l'ensemble de ces de ces rapports
il est indiqué dans le rapport qu'il est
peu probable qu'au cours des prochaines
années les recettes fiscales affichent
le même dynamisme
considérez-vous que l'élasticité très
forte des recettes à la croissance
connue en 2022 2,2 risque de ne pas se
reproduire à ce que c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre par ailleurs le gouvernement
nous dit régulièrement que la diminution
des taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés
permet aux entreprises d'améliorer leur
situation et finalement d'accroître les
recettes dièses vos analyses vous
permettent-elles d'apprécier ou pas un
tel effet
et pour ma seconde question je
reviendrai sur la question
de l'inflation nous constatons un écart
important entre la prévision et
l'exécution
et qui concerne la part de la charge de
la dette relative au titre indexée à
cause de l'inflation les titres indexés
ont coûté 15 milliards et demi d'euros
alors que le coût prévisionnel était de
4,1 vous proposez de développer
d'actualiser la documentation publique
sur les modalités de recours au titre de
dette indexées en quoi le suivi de ces
titres indexés est-il insuffisant et
cela permettrait-il de réduire
l'exposition de la charge de la dette
aux aléas de l'inflation ce qui est bien
l'objectif recherché me semble-t-il
voilà pour mes questions peut-être bien
sûr Jean-François Husson le rapporteur
général qui suit toutes ces questions
budgétaires globales avec c'est une
grande attention Jean-François oui merci
monsieur le Président et merci madame la
Présidente pour la présentation vous
nous avez faite qui je dois le dire ne
me rassure pas puisqu'elle s'inscrit
dans le droit fil de d'un certain nombre
de nos constats observations et j'ai
bien en tête encore le dernier débat
budgétaire avec un ministre nous
expliquant qu'il était sur un budget à
l'euro près
alors la question de la proximité et de
la comment dirais-je de la précision
me paraît je pense qu'on pourrait faire
un
comment dirais soumettre à la fois la
représentation nationale mais également
un certain nombre d'experts sur ça veut
dire quoi à l'Europe lorsque l'on
regarde et vous l'avez souligné
la largesse des reports de crédit
inédits nous l'avons souligné nous très
tôt pour l'instant c'est plutôt passé
sous les radars de l'actualité parce que
c'est évidemment moins trash qu'un
certain nombre d'événements mais et vous
l'avez dit quand on conjugue ces
observations avec la remontée des taux
on s'aperçoit que
nos finalement notre budget il est
quelque part en apesanteur et qu'on a un
risque d'atterrissage particulièrement
douloureux
à la fois sur la charge financière liée
à nos déficits et puisque c'est en
pleine actualité quand on ajoute la
fameuse dette climatique
ça va être ça risque d'être
particulièrement violent avec
pour avoir toujours émis beaucoup de
réserves
sur le budget dit budget vert de l'État
je pense que quand on fait un effort il
vaut mieux prendre un peu de temps
essayer de faire en sorte d'apprécier le
la couleur verte en tous les cas
l'empreinte écologique environnementale
ne dépense si c'est pour se prononcer
sur 10% des dépenses excusez-moi du peu
mais c'est vraiment vraiment pas la
hauteur et je le redis je pense qu'il
faut moins communiquer
et dire de manière plus claire même si
c'est parfois douloureux dans
l'expression il faut dire la vérité
surtout sur les chiffres parce que la
précision des chiffres et leur
exactitude conditionne des choix pour
demain je vais reprendre là aussi vous
avez évoqué je partage pour le dire
depuis un certain temps proposer à nos
assemblées des votes sur des lois de
programmation militaire santé justice
on est évidemment on a toujours envie
d'avoir davantage de dépenses mais
ensuite quand d'autres événements
arrivent et viennent percuter les
réalités il faut accepter de
reconsidérer la chose sinon on est dans
une espèce de dépendance que vous avez
rappelé par la dégradation de nos
comptes publics par l'envoler des
déficits enfin le déficit si on regarde
sur les dépenses sans plus de 160
milliards
pour 2022 qui pose d'ailleurs
à mon avis et c'est ce que je vous pose
également comme question sur cette
évolution c'est
j'entends qu'il va y avoir une
dixit le ministre de l'économie et des
finances une revue des dépenses
publiques pour normalement je cite
toujours produire plusieurs milliards
d'euros d'économies
165 milliards
pouvez-vous en tous les cas
apprécier
quel montant d'économie serait
susceptible aux yeux des chiffres dont
nous disposons et que vous avez analysé
qu'elle pourrait être l'effet et quel
montant en termes d'économie
s'agissant vous l'avez dit des
prévisions de recettes évidemment comme
vous j'attends beaucoup plus de
précisions sur les hypothèses retenues
dans les collectifs budgétaires
puisqu'on voit bien qu'il y a une espèce
de forme de cavalerie avec les reports
etc mais
quels sont selon vous les raisons qui
expliquent ces écarts constatés entre
des prévisions et puis dont on voit que
c'est d'ailleurs plutôt à la fin de
l'année
où finalement les recettes effectivement
constatées ne sont pas à la hauteur des
prévisions j'ai entendu un votre
recommandation mais faut-il dans ce
cas-là proposer des changements de
méthodes et si oui lesquels et selon
finalement quel mode opératoire et puis
dernière question qui concerne la
certification des comptes qui me paraît
là aussi être finalement le gage en tout
cas le pendant de la bonne tenue des
comptes
vous avez vous l'avez rappelé
refusé cette année de certifier les
comptes de la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale et de la CNAV
s'agissant de l'État vous avez certifié
évidemment la régularité la sincérité
des comptes mais avec un certain nombre
de réserves que je qualifierais de
notables notamment sur la participation
les participations de l'État dans EDF
est dans la Caisse des Dépôts
est-ce que vous vous avez des
explications à nous fournir
éventuellement sur les raisons qui
conduisent le gouvernement à ne pas
suivre vos recommandations dont je
rappelle qu'elles ne sont pas que des
recommandations pour cette année
doit-on enfin que doit-on déduire et que
pourrait-on proposer
merci beaucoup alors je vais jouer
commencer à répondre sur le dynamisme
des recettes fiscales parce
qu'évidemment c'est un point extrêmement
important alors peut-être déjà il faut
comprendre pourquoi il y a eu un tel
rebond cette année
ce rebond je le rappelle c'est quand
même 27 milliards de plus de recettes
que prévu ce qui représente 9,7% du
montant total de ces recettes alors tout
d'abord il y a un impact de l'inflation
cet impact de l'inflation il a pesé sur
la TVA qui a augmenté de 9,4%
soit
1,6 fois plus vite que la croissance du
PIB en valeur et puis il y a eu un
impact aussi sur l'impôt sur le revenu
pourquoi parce que il y a eu les
augmentations de salaire l'ambassade a
suivi bien sûr en partie l'augmentation
des prix et cet impact est quand même de
11 milliards donc ça n'est pas nul mais
je dirais que le principal impact c'est
quand même celui qui pèse sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés pourquoi parce qu'il y
a eu en 200021 une croissance du
bénéfice fiscal des entreprises de 41%
c'est considérable c'est lié évidemment
à la très forte croissance peut-être
aussi au niveau des aides dont on
bénéficier les entreprises au cours de
cette période quand même
particulièrement compliqué difficile
pour pour tous et ça a joué positivement
sur les acomptes qui ont été versés par
les entreprises en cours d'année et sur
le sol de verser en 2022 donc on voit
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant que les
acomptes de fin d'année 2022 n'ont pas
diminué ce qui montre qu'il y a quand
même une anticipation assez favorable
des entreprises sur une certaine
poursuite de l'activité économique
il y a eu deux baisses comme je le
rappelais la TICE à cause du bouclier
tarifaire énergétique et puis bien sûr
la redevance audiovisuelle mais bien
entendu les l'évolution reste
globalement très positive alors est-ce
que ça va se poursuivre
probablement pas les anticipations que
nous faisons et dont nous rendrons
compte d'ailleurs prochainement de
rendre d'autres rapports et notamment le
rapport qui sortira en juin sur la
situation des finances publiques
montrent que du fait de la baisse de la
croissance bien évidemment
l'élasticité des recettes fiscales en
2023 devrait être inférieur à 1 alors
qu'elle est supérieure très nettement
cette année donc il ne faut pas
s'attendre à avoir une augmentation
identique des recettes fiscales l'année
prochaine ça c'est
c'est parfaitement clair
sur
l'impact de l'inflation sur la charge de
la dette alors bon effectivement il y a
deux effets dans l'augmentation de la
charge de la dette cette année il y a un
effet volume qui est lié à
l'augmentation de l'encours je l'ai
rappelé cette augmentation est quand
même très importante et puis il y a
évidemment la constitution de provision
pour charge d'indexation dans les contes
de l'État qui correspondent à
l'indexation des coupons qui vont être
versés aux détenteurs de ces titres au
cours de des mois qui viennent les fait
tôt en 2022 il est nul c'est trop tôt en
revanche il va évidemment peser en 2023
avec la le recul attendu de l'inflation
pourrait avoir une diminution de la
charge d'intérêt lié aux obligations
indexées en revanche les faitos va
devenir prépondérant dans l'augmentation
de la charge de la date l'année
prochaine alors on peut se demander
pourquoi
l'Agence France Trésor continue dans
cette période compliquée en termes
d'inflation à émettre des OAT indexées
en fait ça correspond quand même à une
demande de certains investisseurs un peu
soin de refinancement sur des titres qui
prennent enfin accepte l'évolution de
l'inflation et puis le volume reste à
peu près constant dans l'ensemble de la
date les obligations indexées
représentent à peu près 10% donc c'est
un poids quand même relativement faible
néanmoins la Cour a effectivement
recommandée
d'actualiser en fait la doctrine de
l'Agence France Trésor sur les
conditions d'émissions indexée parce que
cette doctrine est un peu ancienne elle
est préalable au choc d'inflation
antérieure au choc d'inflation donc il y
a effectivement nécessité de revoir et
nous savons que c'est en cours
donc voilà pour ce qui concerne l'impact
de l'inflation sur les taux alors pour
répondre à vos questions monsieur le
rapporteur général
la précision des prévisions budgétaires
étaient effectivement peut-être un peu
compliqué en période à la fois de fin de
crise sanitaire et puis aussi
d'évolution quand même très forte de la
situation internationale avec le choc de
consécutifs à la guerre en Ukraine
l'inflation qui était préalable qui a
été accentuée par l'augmentation des
coûts de l'énergie et donc on peut
comprendre qu'il y ait des réajustements
nécessaires en cours d'année c'est
d'ailleurs sans doute pour cette raison
qu'il y a eu décret d'avance et de loi
de finances rectificatives néanmoins
nous constatons quand même qu'il y a
effectivement
des sous-consommation très importantes
de crédit j'ai rappelé les chiffres tout
à l'heure et donc il y a eu
principalement des sous-consommation sur
le plan de relance qui ne va pas
peut-être aussi vite que cela était
prévu il y a eu également des
sous-consommation sur la mission
économie notamment par exemple
l'aide aux entreprises énergo intensives
n'a pas été consommé du tout au niveau
pour lequel elle avait été budgétée il y
a eu aussi ponctuellement d'autres
sous-consommation par exemple sur le
plan d'aide aux demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée qui n'a pas été mis non
plus enfin consommé au rythme attendu
donc au final beaucoup de mises en
réserve et donc effectivement un certain
flou je dirais alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour améliorer
je pense que déjà bon la conjoncture se
stabilise quand même un petit peu donc
on peut espérer que les prévisions
seront plus fiables
nous nous pensons qu'elles peuvent
l'être et peut-être d'ailleurs les
revues de dépenses permettront de
contribuer à y voir plus clair dans un
certain nombre de postes budgétaires
ça reste évidemment un exercice à mener
alors vous évoquez le montant des
économies attendues par ces revues de
dépenses là je dois dire que je peux
malheureusement donner aucune précision
la Cour va contribuer à ces revues de
dépenses mais elles sont en cours nous
en faisons nous-mêmes de notre côté et
nous identifions sur un certain nombre
de
politiques publiques
démarches de manœuvre je pense je l'ai
cité tout à l'heure les dépenses
fiscales vous allez me dire c'est un
quelque chose qui revient depuis
longtemps mais néanmoins il y a
certainement matière quand on voit leur
augmentation
il y a aussi peut-être sur des groupes
budgets comme les aides au logement des
évolutions possibles qui permettraient
de faire des économies mais les revues
de dépenses elles sont certes conçues
pour faire des économies mais aussi pour
améliorer la qualité de la dépense
c'est-à-dire en fait l'efficience c'est
la question de l'atteinte des résultats
obtenus avec des masses de crédit aussi
importantes est-ce que vraiment les
résultats sont en rendez-vous et ça
c'est extrêmement important aussi
dépenser moins bien sûr c'est nécessaire
des pensées plus enfin dépenser mieux
pardon c'est également indispensable
je ne prétends pas ce sacerdoce
[Rires]
nous serons d'accord sur ce point avec
elle alors mais comme vous le savez elle
a annoncé hier je crois un gel
supplémentaire de 1% sur les dépenses
des ministères qui s'ajoutent au 5 %
donc voilà alors un petit point sur
l'endettement parce que
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
cet endettement il a augmenté de 24% en
3 ans
il est devenu effectivement considérable
on va enregistrer avec la hausse des
taux d'intérêt
une augmentation très certainement de la
charge de la dette alors peut-être pas
en 2023 parce que ça met un petit peu de
temps bien sûr au fur et à mesure du
renouvellement des des émissions pour se
traduire dans la charge de la dette en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que le
l'impact du déficit et majeur et donc si
on veut revenir à une trajectoire plus
proche de celle du projet de loi de
programmation pour les finances
publiques ou
voilà qui est toujours un projet mais la
Cour espère bien sûr appel de ses
nouvelles lois de programmation le
premier président de l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises ou bien
s'inscrire dans les perspectives
énoncées par la Commission européenne
sur les nouvelles règles futures bien
effectivement il y aura beaucoup à faire
et vous parliez des lois de
programmation sur les finances publiques
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques a
eu l'occasion de rappeler que si on
souhaite revenir à 3% de déficits
publics en 2027 et bien il faudrait que
compte tenu justement du poids des
dépenses rigidifiées par les lois de
programmation il faudrait que les autres
dépenses de l'État baisse de 1,4% en
volume chaque année c'est un effort qui
paraît difficile
difficile voilà
compte tenu de ce qu'on connaît sur la
dynamique de la dépense publique on n'a
pas de précédent qui permettent de nous
rassurer sur l'atteinte de cette
prévision donc voilà alors
ce que je peux vous dire à ce stade
peut-être un petit mot alors sur les
changements de méthode par rapport aux
recettes je n'avoue que je n'ai pas de
je n'ai pas de réponse
facile à vous donner il faut
certainement que il y ait des
instruments au niveau de la DG FIP
notamment qui permettent de mieux
appréhender plutôt et plus finement les
évolutions
d'assiettes qui explique ce meilleur
rendement de l'impôt que nous constatons
ça remet un petit peu en lumière le
travail qui reste à faire dans ce
domaine enfin sur
les les
réserves que nous indiquons dans
l'acte de certification qui font l'objet
notamment de remarques sur la Caisse des
dépôts et EDF sur la Caisse des Dépôts
c'est un désaccord très ancien que nous
avons avec la direction générale du
Trésor sur la façon de comptabiliser
dans les comptes la participation de
l'État à la Caisse des Dépôts c'est une
question assez technique finalement de
classement comptable ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la loi pacte un petit peu
modifié la donne puisque elle a quand
même prévu un certain nombre de
dispositions qui indiquent notamment que
le directeur général de la Caisse d'EPO
est nommé par le gouvernement enfin qui
a rapproché quand même un petit peu le
la Caisse des dépôts de de
de l'État et donc nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec la direction générale du
Trésor sur ce qu'il convient de retenir
dans les contes de l'État sur EDF
en fait il y a dans les contes d'EDF un
certain nombre de titres qui
n'appartiennent pas à l'état et qui
n'ont pas été déduits de l'assiette qui
permet de
d'intégrer la valeur d'équivalence dans
les contes de l'État là aussi c'est
assez technique je pense que c'est un
point sur lequel nous pourrons
progresser dans les années qui viennent
et je ne suis pas très inquiète sur
cette sur cet aspect
pardon d'avoir été un petit peu long
merci madame la Présidente tout va bien
quoi qu'on approche
de midi donc je vais demander à mes
collègues qui sont inscrits au nombre de
7 pour le moment j'irai d'essayer d'être
d'être concis et on va essayer de
grouper l'ensemble de ces
questionnements les noterez pour
répondre ensuite donc nous commençons
par Jérôme Bacher puis marque Lamini
je serai pas tellement concis monsieur
le Président désolé de vous non mais je
vais essayer d'être simple résumé en
deux temps l'autorisation parlementaire
d'un côté et de l'autre côté les sujets
de charge d'intérêt et de dettes sur
l'autorisation parlementaire vous enfin
le pré le premier président appellent à
ce qu'il y a une nouvelle loi de
programmation des finances publiques moi
on n'appelle pas à ça nous on appelle ça
au respect d'une loi de programmation
des finances publiques car vous l'avez
souligné dès le départ c'est les forces
structurelles n'a pas été au rendez-vous
il aurait fallu selon la loi réviser
cette loi de programmation or cela n'a
pas été fait et si on n'a pas été fait
quasiment depuis le début car dès la
première année je le rappelle monsieur
le Président vous étiez le Président la
Commission à ce moment-là
en titre et pas momentané et pas par
intérêt
dès la première année il y a eu des
rives
l'autre programmation des sciences
physiques t'as pas été respecté dès la
première année donc voilà et d'ailleurs
vous le rappelez d'être dans un second
temps lorsque vous soulignez vous-même
que la loi de finance rectificative dont
on a voulu modifier un peu le contour en
disant qu'on était plus de mesures
fiscale c'était presque une pré loi de
règlement et c'est cela la réforme de la
loi organique sur les lois de finances
et bien cette loi de financement
rectificative vous l'avez dit c'est
éloigné encore plus de l'atterrissage
que nous avons vu en 2021 donc nos
respects de la loi organique non respect
de la loi de programmation des finances
publiques
et puis vous le soulignez aussi on a
quand même un sujet majeur sur les
reports autant en 2020 situation
exceptionnelle nous comprenons
l'explosion des reports
en 2021 passe encore on est à la limite
sur le covid en 2022 il n'y a plus une
seule raison et vous soulignez par
ailleurs que les restes à réaliser ne
cesse de s'accroître eux aussi report de
crédit d'à côté et reste à réaliser sont
encore plus importants sont encore plus
importants donc on est là vraiment sur
une dérive complète de nos finances
publiques parce que c'est de la dette
sous la ligne et j'en viens mon deuxième
à ma deuxième partie
la dette vous y avez répondu en partie
madame la Présidente sur les la dette
indexée inflation alors je vous invite à
lire un très bon rapport que j'ai commis
ce qui vous aurait peut-être évité petit
approximation sur le fait que la dette
indexée inflation depuis sa création en
auquel j'ai justement participé au début
de ma carrière
et bien et encore aujourd'hui à sol de
positif et ça il faut que tout le monde
l'ait en tête car pendant longtemps cela
a été un bénéfice pour les contribuables
pour la charge de notre dette que des
maîtres avec des doigtés indexées
inflation
il est vrai que tout cela était gobé
d'un coup d'un seul en 2022 donc on voit
bien de façon il y a pas il est assez
logique je crois en macroéconomique à la
fin
l'inflation et les anticipations de
l'inflation tout ça revient sur la norme
à la fin et donc c'est le point
d'équilibre et bien c'est essentiel
cette eau ATI parce que qui la détient
qu'il a détient mes chers collègues
c'est la Caisse des Dépôts c'est le
livret A qui est le principal détenteur
ce sont nos économies
c'est le fait d'avoir quelque chose de
très stable sur
ce point ce point-là pour rembourser le
fait pour rémunérer nos épargnants donc
là dessus je ne suis pas totalement
d'accord avec votre recommandation sur
les eaux ATI et puis c'est un sujet
essentiel pour la dette française qui
est bientôt l'année prochaine cette
année en 2023 pardon qui sera la
première dette européenne en niveau plus
que la dette italienne en niveau
c'est absolument incroyable
et c'est ça liquidité qui fait
aujourd'hui son prix relativement
modeste et c'est sa seule liquidité et
pour qui est liquidité il faut surtout
pas changer de politique sur l'émission
car sinon le marché ne vous fait plus
confiance et à ce moment-là nous
retrouverons dans les taux d'intérêt
eux-mêmes
auquel nous empruntons sur l'ensemble de
la courbe sur l'ensemble des produits
une charge bien supérieure
et c'est donc la même idée sur le budget
vert et j'attends de lire avec attention
parce que là aussi je crois avoir
combien un rapport là-dessus qui dit
c'est une chance aussi de d'émettre et
d'avoir été longtemps le premier
émetteur de dette verte ça participe
aussi à écouler notre dette car c'est la
dernière chose et j'en conclus ce qui
fait notre force aujourd'hui et notre
bonne émission de dette c'est ça
liquidité c'est-à-dire sa taille sa
profondeur la diversité de ces produits
car ce n'est plus hélas la crédi la
crédibilité de notre trajectoire de
finances publiques
merci Jérôme Marc Lamy
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente et la Cour
des comptes sur le rapporteur général
cher collègue je le ferai avec beaucoup
moins de talents que Jérôme qui m'a
précédé mais
j'aurais juste deux trois observations
déjà
concernant
le la présentation de ce travail de fond
et d'expertise bon c'est vrai que les
charges plus de 500 milliards d'euros
les produits
341 milliards d'euros et donc
les chiffres sont réellement parlant
alors je voudrais revenir sur la page 14
qui fait une bonne synthèse entre l'État
le lien entre l'État les collectivités
territoriales et c'est vrai que
historiquement l'État reste le premier
partenaire des collectivités
territoriales ça soit les communes
intercommunalités département région
vous avez tout à fait raison de
d'insister sur la notion de complexité
alors c'est vrai que ça s'élève à 143
milliards d'euros ce qui est quand même
particulièrement important et c'est
aussi le débat qu'on a souvent en
commission des finances mais aussi en
séance sur l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales et qu'elle
sont un peu ma question sur l'évolution
et le devenir de de ce partenariat entre
l'État les collectivités territoriales
puis j'aurais aussi une dernière
question
concernant les les recettes parce que le
tout c'est que conforter les l'évolution
des recettes de l'État de cette fiscale
notamment
vous avez évoqué madame la Présidente la
baisse des effectifs de certaines
administrations certains services de
l'État notamment le ministère de
l'économie et des finances et je
voudrais aborder le sujet justement de
la lutte contre la fraude et il y a
quand même des manques à gagner et c'est
vrai que les moyens humains ils sont là
aussi pour essayer de de conforter les
recettes de l'État et et on sait qu'il y
a un combat aussi sur la lutte contre la
fraude et peut-on estimer
au mont le montant de de la fraude en la
matière voilà je vous remercie
merci Marc Isabelle briquet puis Michel
calotte Isabelle merci monsieur le
Président
merci madame la Présidente de nous avoir
présenté ce rapport ce matin et surtout
d'avoir appelé la nécessité de de
respecter le principe d'annualité et de
spécialités budgétaire puisque on
commençait à l'oublier depuis quelques
temps et c'est vrai que je souscris
pleinement à cette recommandation et si
on pouvait avoir
et s'il est à pouvait
la suivre dans
au sens vraiment le plus strict possible
ça nous arrangerait parce que ça faut
reconnaître que c'est admis quand même
grandement
au travail du Parlement
l'importance des reports vous les avez
soulignés enfin c'est ça nous rend la
tâche bien difficile pour avoir un avis
objectif sur la
le budget de l'État
par ailleurs vous l'avez souligné aussi
on observe en 2022 le dynamisme des
recettes mais avec à côté de ces
recettes une une augmentation importante
de la dépense et une augmentation de la
charge de la dette qui ne va que
s'accroître puisque pour l'instant il y
a pas encore l'effet tôt mais on va on
va le percevoir très très rapidement
donc on a globalement un volume et de
dettes et de dépenses qui va qui va
augmenter pour autant si certaines
recettes augmentent nous voyons bien que
les besoins à venir pour financer
notamment à la reconversion écologique
sont sont très importantes pensez-vous
qu'ils soient judicieux du coup de se
priver de de recettes par un désarmement
fiscal continu puisque ça fait plusieurs
années où on se prive allègrement de
certaines de certaines recettes et alors
qu'on nous annonce de nouveau
allègements fiscaux voici mon
questionnement merci
Isabelle Michel cannelette et puis
ensuite Stéphane sotarella Michel deux
questions madame la Présidente on vous
remercions de votre présentation tout
d'abord sur le slide 15 vous évoquez sur
les restes à payer alors qu'ils
augmentaient de façon régulière jusqu'en
2020 une très forte augmentation 126
milliards à 214 entre 2020 et 2022
qu'est-ce qui explique qu'il y est une
telle augmentation est-ce que cela est
inquiétant pour nos finances publiques
première question et puis deuxième
question dans votre propos tout à
l'heure vous avez évoqué l'approche
verte de considération de des impacts
sur l'environnement que la Cour
entendait mener et notamment la
publication prochaine d'un rapport à ce
sujet et j'ai lu hier dans les échos
qu'effectivement la cour préconisait la
réduction du cheptel bovin
alors ceci m'inquiète particulièrement
parce que on doit parler également de
souveraineté alimentaire et on doit
parler de capacité à
conserver le milieu rural et ce type de
préconisation madame la Présidente je
dois l'avouer m'inquiète tout
particulièrement à ce que vous entendez
poursuivre en ce sens
merci Michel Stéphane sotorel puis
Christian BIAC oui merci monsieur le
Président Madame madame la Présidente
j'avais trois trois questions ou trois
remarques mais je ne peux que rebondir
je pensais que c'était un port sujet
mais puisque Michel cannelle là il a
évoqué sur effectivement le
[Musique]
ne sera pas encore pleine en 23 mais
davantage en 24 est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur
l'impact de volume qui déjà était
présent 22 et qui en 23 va être aussi
considérable au-delà de des remarques à
faire j'ai embachère déjà sur la partie
wati deuxième remarque c'est sur les
dépenses fiscales sur lesquelles vous
avez insisté sur leur dynamisme leur
niveau et j'aurai une question
complémentaire sur leur évolution et
leur part relatives par rapport à
l'ensemble du niveau de de la dépense
qui est en constante augmentation et je
pense qu'effectivement c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous serons amenés à
travailler et puis le troisième élément
concerne le les transferts entre l'État
et les collectivités territoriales vous
avez souligné à raison que depuis 2021
il y a un accroissement et en tout cas
une part de TVA considérable qui vient
modifier les équilibres suite à
différentes décisions fiscales en
particulier
mais il y a un autre élément qui est peu
commenté c'est la baisse en revanche de
la contrepartie des dégrèvements et
cette un élément particulièrement
inquiétant puisque les dégrèvements ont
de qualité c'est qu'à la fois il permet
de garder une dynamique et une
territorialisation de l'impôt ce qu'on
avait recommandé dans la réforme de la
CVAE et qui n'a pas été entendu or là le
constat que l'on fait c'est que la part
relative des compensations liées au
dégrèvement est en constante diminution
ce qui est aussi un facteur d'inquiétude
quant à la dynamique des ressources et à
l'autonomie des ressources des
collectivités merci
merci Stéphane Christian BIAC puis
Daniel loyer Christian merci monsieur le
Président merci madame la Présidente
si je devais limiter à 10 mots une
intervention je ferai bref rassurez-vous
je dirais 160 milliards de déficits et
le non respect des grands principes
budgétaires de la comptabilité publique
qu'on apprend la première semaine on
étudie
ce sujet à l'université au bout de 15
jours on a appris ça et là c'est pas
respecté
les recettes fiscales donc ça devenait
un peu notre tradition c'était car entre
les prévisions
et
faire le fait d'aller ou le règlement
mais je crains fort que cette tradition
soit abandonnée étant donné l'optimisme
des prévisions pour le budget en cours
je crois que cette tradition qui
finalement n'était pas si mauvaise de
voir augmenter les recettes fiscales on
l'abandonne très rapidement pour revenir
peut-être à des cruelles surprises
les dépenses bien on voit bien vous avez
il y a un chiffre qui interpelle quand
même 33% de dépenses
d'augmentation par rapport à 2019
c'est-à-dire avant le covid 33%
c'est énorme et cette année on avait
quand même 47 milliards de
d'économie possible sur
covid soutien orange ce qui aurait
permis si on avait réaffecté ces 47
milliards aux autres dépenses de l'État
d'arriver à repasser sous la barre du
budget à 400 milliards
de l'État une augmentation de l'ordre
10% ce qui est quand même quelque chose
de convenable me semble-t-il mais ça n'a
pas été fait désolé
les règles les report le crédit
engurgence et relance qui
traditionnellement est aux alentours
d'un pour cent ça varie un peu en dessus
en dessous on passe à 8%
je passe rapidement sur le reste à
réaliser pour conclure avec les
collectivités locales alors cocorico 143
milliards on est les meilleurs mais
c'est pas le discours comme tiennent les
maires que je rencontre chaque semaine
Stéphane la souligné déjà
mais c'est plus long ça ne trompe pas
l'oeil donc évidemment un concours de
l'État phénoménal mais à côté des
charges qui pèsent et des suppressions
d'impôts ces concours ils ne font que
compenser le suppression d'impôts donc
c'est vraiment un affichage un peu
facile à faire mais moi j'ai lu encore
une fois que je
rencontre avec je débat tous ces chemins
ils me disent pas ce que je suis
merveilleux voilà avec quelques
remarques que je voulais faire merci
Christian Daniel Breuillet puis on
terminera avec Arnaud Besan je soustrais
ce que vient de dire on est bien
que sur les sur les collectivités je
voulais comme mes collègues mes
collègues vous merci madame la
Présidente du coup je vais limiter à un
seul sujet qui est le sujet climatique
le budget vert et une ou deux questions
d'abord vous évoquez le budget vert avec
en disant c'est un outil très imparfait
mais au moins on a un outil bon les
outils sont faits pour être utilisés et
moi si j'ai bien compris et je voulais
votre confirmation par exemple les
dépenses
d'aide d'aide
à l'essence à la oui d'aide à la
consommation
d'essence au moment de la crise
pétrolière ne figure pas dans les
dépenses brunes c'est quand même assez
étonnant quand on quand on s'interroge
sur ce qu'est une dépense brune qui est
plutôt une dépense qui mobilise du du
pétrole et qui a du coup des
conséquences négatives en termes
d'émission de CO2 je dois dire je
comprends pas pourquoi c'est une dépense
neutre enfin qui n'est pas classée en
dépense brune et du coup j'ai un doute
au fond sur l'efficacité d'un outil qui
n'est pas capable de dire ce qui est une
dépense brune et ce qui est réellement
une dépense verte et je préfère le
rapport de Pisani ferry à un budget vert
parce qu'au moins il ouvre des pistes
d'action mais ce sur quoi je voulais
vous questionner c'est que vous
présentez un budget préoccupant enfin un
tableau préoccupant mais pas surprenant
mais ce tableau est d'autant plus
préoccupant qu'il y a des transitions à
faire et donc je partage le point de vue
de ma collègue briquet peut-on faire ses
transitions sans avoir des recettes
supplémentaires est-ce qu'on peut
simplement à chaque fois par une baisse
de la dépense se garantir la capacité
par exemple à éviter des dépenses
futures et je pense particulièrement et
évidemment aux investissements dans la
transition écologique car les coûts de
la non-adaptation de notre pays à la
crise climatique seront des coûts
extrêmement élevés et donc il vaut mieux
sans doute
des dépenses aujourd'hui que des
dépenses accrues demain voilà c'était
une question sur la façon dont on
regarde au fond c'est ses dépenses et
notamment dans cet effort de transition
et ce que le seul regard budgétaire
évidemment ne peut suffire à nous donner
les capacités de faire face à ces
transitions nécessaires merci Daniel
Arnaud voisin merci monsieur le
Président de la présidente j'avais une
question sur le maintien de l'émission
doater indexée sur l'inflation mais je
dois dire que le cours magistral du
fonctionnaire de Bercy pardon du
sénateur Jérôme Bacher m'a édifié sous
réserve toutefois madame le présidente
que vous confirmiez que les
bénéficiaires de ces oité en tout cas
les acheteurs de ces Oates indexées sur
l'inflation sont bien en effet ceux qui
ont été indiqués par Jérôme Bacher et
que c'est pas une Opport pour des
investisseurs privés de trouver là une
source de revenus et ma deuxième
question portait sur les transferts
financiers et des concours de l'État aux
collectivité
dans le prolongement de la question de
Stéphane sautorel on observe qu'en 2020
on est après de 23 milliards d'euros qui
sont des contreparties de dégrèvement
qui ne sont plus que 7 milliards d'euros
en 2022 alors bien sûr tout ça s'inscrit
dans un remaniement fiscal général mais
ce que vous pouvez donner un peu plus de
précision sur ces transferts et cette
baisse de 23 à 7 milliards
merci Arnaud alors madame la Présidente
exercice difficile pour vous de répondre
l'ensemble de ces questionnements dans
un délai raisonnable mais on va vous
donner quand même le temps de développer
la pensée de la cour je vais essayer de
faire au mieux alors un point sur
l'intervention monsieur sénateur votre
intervention concernant notre
recommandation sur les eaux ATI le
propos de la Cour n'est pas de dire
qu'il faudrait en diminuer le montant
dans l'ensemble des volumes des missions
il est plutôt de dire que il faut
réexaminer quand même un petit peu la
doctrine à la lumière de l'augmentation
de l'inflation quitte peut-être
d'ailleurs à maintenir l'en cours actuel
si il apparaît comme vous étiez très
justement que ça répond aux besoins de
certains
organismes et notamment de la Caisse des
Dépôts donc il est nécessaire
effectivement que l'Agence France 13h
diversifie les
les propositions qu'elle fait au marché
et les eaux ATI en font partie
simplement les situations radicalement
changé quand même avec l'augmentation de
l'inflation et ça c'est un site à la
prudence d'autant plus qu'il va y avoir
l'impact de la hausse des taux et qu'on
ne sait pas très bien si l'inflation va
diminuer et à quel rythme donc ça c'est
le premier point ensuite sur
la question de du respect de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
en fait le la question qui me semble
vraiment importante c'est celle de la
sortie programmée normalement pour la
fin de l'année de la clause de
circonstances exceptionnelles qui dont
on ne connaît pas encore très bien comme
je le disais tout à l'heure les
conditions puisque c'est en cours de
discussion mais qui certainement nous
contraindre beaucoup plus en termes de
dépenses publiques et de solde puisqu'il
va falloir se mettre dans une
trajectoire à 4 ans de d'atteindre d'un
niveau de 3% en 2027 ce qui
effectivement compte tenu des des
propos que j'ai enfin de ce que je viens
de présenter va exiger des efforts
importants
un point sur la lutte contre la fraude
aujourd'hui je suis bien ennuyée pour
vous donner un chiffrage parce qu'il
n'est pas fait par la Direction générale
des finances publiques qui ne mesure pas
ce qu'on appelle l'écart fiscal qui est
le la différence entre ce que les impôts
devraient rapporter s'il n'y avait pas
de fraude et ce qu'il rapporte
effectivement donc il y a nous l'avons
fait remarquer par des rapports et nous
sommes d'ailleurs encore sur ce sujet
actuellement et il y a des travaux en
cours à la direction générale pas mal de
finances publiques pour essayer de
progresser dans ce domaine là notamment
depuis l'annonce du ministre de
l'Économie des Finances sur le enfin
chargé des comptes publics plutôt sur la
question de la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale pour la diminution des impôts
bon ce cas dit le premier président bien
sûr vous le savez certainement c'est que
il était difficilement envisageable
aujourd'hui de programmer des baisses
d'impôts qui ne seraient pas
intégralement compensé on peut
difficilement imaginer qu'il y ait de
nouvelles baisses qui ne soient pas
compensées je rappellerai quand même que
le taux de prélèvement obligatoire
aujourd'hui en France et le plus élevé
de la zone euro donc la marge de
manœuvre
est quand même pour créer de nouveaux
impôts est un petit peu
compliqué et pour les baisser comme on
n'a pas de marge de manœuvre de
budgétaire
c'est également complexe
en ce qui concerne les restes à payer
alors pourquoi cette augmentation
l'essentiel des restes à payer vient
comme je le disais en partie de
l'évolution des de cette masse de crédit
qui n'était pas véritablement affectée
et des reports mais surtout du programme
France relance qui n'a pas été exécuté
au rythme attendu et ça représente la
moitié des restes à payer qui sont
constatés
en ce qui concerne
les transferts de l'État aux
collectivités locales alors le rapport
donne les grands ordres de grandeur et
montrent que les prélèvements sur
Recettes représentent à peu près un
tiers la fiscalité transférée un autre
tiers la TVA un troisième tiers et que
les dépenses budgétaires sont assez
faibles montants
je voudrais rappeler qu'il va y avoir
bientôt un rapport qui va être
présenté par la Cour qui va concerner
comme tous les ans les finances
publiques locales et qui va donner un
état à jour de leur situation financière
donc on devrait pouvoir mieux mesurer
les cette situation qui recouvre certes
beaucoup de disparité mais qui dans
l'ensemble enfin la Cour l'a déjà
constaté l'année dernière n'est pas
mauvaise
l'état ayant quand même largement
compenser les les diminutions de
recettes alors il y a eu un rapport qui
avait été remis d'ailleurs à la
commission des finances l'année dernière
sur les scénarios de financement des
collectivités locales qui dressaient un
certain nombre de perspectives pour
l'avenir sur la situation plus
particulière des dégrèvements
alors oui il y a eu effectivement ce
problème lié à la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation mais si on fait
la somme des pertes et en même temps on
la compare à l'importance des transferts
c'est équilibrée il n'y a pas de même
les transferts de TVA suite à la réforme
de la TH et des impôts de production
sont plus élevés
que que la
totalité des mesures de suppression donc
faudrait faire un point plus précis je
n'ai pas d'éléments aujourd'hui mais
globalement c'est équilibré et enfin sur
les mesures
énergies qui étaient côté neutre
effectivement en 2022 elle devrait être
côté en tout cas pour partie brune à
partir de 2023 je voudrais rappeler
quand même que la direction du budget
est assez
volontariste sur ce sujet et qu'elle
essaye de côté le plus grand nombre de
dépenses possible pour cela il faut
qu'elle dispose de tous les éléments qui
peuvent lui être communiqués par les
ministères donc on peut espérer quand
même une amélioration du taux
de dépenses côté vertes et brunes voilà
ce que je peux dire pour répondre à ces
rapidement aux questions qui ont été
posées monsieur le Président
assez précis
ce qui est le propre du travail de notre
commission surtout quand on est sur des
sujets aussi chiffrés que ceux de ce
matin merci à vous tous
bonne fin de journée pour mes collègues
rendez-vous dans l'après-midi
avec le texte des douanes
enfin QG déjà